the best medicine is closing the border
with China that's the demand from
thousands of striking Hong Kong health
care workers want from their government
I hope the government listens to our
demands quickly closes all the borders
and brings this epidemic under control
it comes as Hong Kong became the second
place outside of the Chinese mainland to
report a death from the coronavirus a 39
year old man who was suffering an
underlying illness traveled to Wuhan in
January Hong Kong's chief executive
criticized the protesters and defended
her decision to leave some parts of the
border open I certainly would not agree
with the allegation that we are sort of
not addressing this public health
concern adequately the alarm has long
since spread across China including to
Shanghai featuring unusually empty
streets but among those out and about
taking precautions is a must I make them
wear masks when they go out when they
come home they have to wash their hands
I believe in our country will overcome
this the number of confirmed infections
rose by several thousand again leaving
many wondering when the worst will be
over more let's bring in Charlotte
chousen Pihl our correspondent in Hong
Kong Charlotte what has been the impact
of this strike regarding the medical
services in the city well this is now
the second day of the five-day strike by
those medical workers here in Hong Kong
sera and authorities are already saying
that there has been a serious impact on
the healthcare community here the
Medical Authority had already warned
that emergency services have been
affected citing in particular cancer
care and neonatal intensive care as well
so there is thumbkin
about these thousands of people who've
walked off the job already and what
could happen in the days ahead
those who are taking part in this strike
though have pointed out that any
disruption to medical services so far
will be nothing compared to the
disruption of a major outbreak of the
new corona virus here in Hong Kong they
are warning but as it stands not enough
preventative measures have been taken
including a full closure of the borders
and they say that they are not
adequately prepared to be able to deal
with a major outbreak but nevertheless I
mean how how much support is there for
these striking personnel because you
know just on the face of it it appears
counterproductive to strike at a time
when the corona virus is indeed
spreading well that certainly has been
the argument from some in the medical
profession warning as you say now is not
the time to walk off the job the chief
executive carry lambs also been urging
medical staff to go back to work - she's
criticised there's strike now what has
to be pointed out is not all medical
staff are taking part in this this is
something that's been organized by a you
knew Union that was set up recently
during the pro-government the
anti-government protests people that
we've spoken to though whether or not
they actually support this strike action
do largely seem to be behind the
motivation for this strike people we
spoke to said that they do want all the
borders with mainland China to be closed
that of course has their those fears
only being increased today by the news
for the 39 year old man who had visited
Wuhan and Maine and China the epicenter
of the outbreak has lost his life today
they've been to more confirmed cases and
the fear that four of those 17 cases now
confirmed may have been transmitted here
in Hong Kong there is no those four
aren't known to have traveled to
mainland China that is something that is
only increasing fear here particularly
in light of the stars epidemic as has
been mentioned in which nearly 300
people lost their lives in this very a
densely populated city so a lot of
people here say they do support the full
closure of the borders here with
mainland China
Charlotte gelsin pill in Hong Kong Thank
You Charlotte